>> Hurrah. Okay. So I thought we'd start off
with an overview of the architecture of the
Wave in a Box software, which is of course
the sort of the main goal of the Wave team
for this year, is to produce Wave in a Box
as a working, federate-able useful wave instance
that you could install inside a small organization
and use for a collaboration and communication
in a small group. So there's been a fantastic
progress already from a--including lots of
good contributions from outside of Google
already going into Wave in a Box so I thought
we'll start off with an architecture of sort
of how that system is going to fit together.
And then throughout the next couple of days,
there'll be more detailed talks on particular
areas of interest inside Wave in a Box and
inside sort of the wave system in general.
So this is a very, very high level view of
how a wave system based on Wave in a Box is
going to work. So the Wave in a Box server
will be a sort of single home instance of
a server. Initially our first goals don't
include sort of scaling to a massive size.
We're going to get something working at a
small scale first. So your Wave in a Box server
will be sitting on a box inside in your own
firewall or possibly, you know, in any kind
of instance hosting environment that you choose
to use. On the left-hand side as you're looking
at it there you can see clients. Clients can
connect over the internet or over your intranet.
Web clients are of course going to be the
most common one, and we, just a few weeks
ago, we launched and hooked up the code that
does a very rich Wave panel inside Wave in
a Box. It's in fact...
>> I'm sorry. Is it possible to assist there...
>> Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> Goodbye, Dan. We can't see you anymore.
>> He left.
>> Okay. Thanks [INDISTINCT]. Right. So just
a couple of weeks ago, we hooked up the Wave--the
new Wave panel. This was in fact the code
we were planning to launch into Google Wave
and so now we've open sourced it instead.
And so there's still a bit of work to go on
that, it's missing a couple of the sort of
UI features that the Google Wave had but they're
on their way. There's also a console client
which we're going to try very hard to keep
working because it's a fantastic debugging
tool [INDISTINCT] for anything else. And then
someone else could write some other kind of
client--maybe only through that way of sort
of planning right now but I already know that
there's people working on iPhone clients and
Android clients and so on. And then those
connect to the Wave in a Box server via the
client server protocol which there'll be more
detail about later on, which runs over a WebSocket
or some kind of socket obstruction for a--and
just as of like a couple of days ago, we can
run on browsers without WebSocket now. The
console client also connects using WebSocket.
And then your Wave in a Box server might offer
other client server protocols as well. For
example, we have a bunch of servlets that
the web--the web client talks to that do things
like pre-fetching of snapshots of data and
so on to make it more efficient. But the co-protocol
run over something like the WebSocket. Then
the server hosts all your waves and at the
other side we have other people's wave servers.
And so this is the federation--federation
side. So other people's Wave in a Box servers
or other Wave servers can communicate with
yours over the Internet using the federation
protocol running over XMPP. And so, you know,
it's our hope that this side of the diagram
becomes a huge web of interconnected wave
servers. Oh, by the way, I should have said,
if you have a question at any point stick
your hand up and ask. Let's get the questions
out early. I will of course have question
time at the end as well. But in case I'm sort
of skipping over something or missing some
detail, raise your hand if you have a question
and we'll get right in to it. Yeah?
>> I have a question. Are the slides available?
Is there a link to these slides?
>> The question was, "Is there a link to the
slides?" There isn't yet but we'll copy all
of these out into the public.
>> I can one.
>> Maybe Pamela can do it now? All right.
Well, Pamela will post something to the forum,
more into the way the live waves when we have
links out there.
>> I have one.
>> Yeah?
>> On those slides, you've mentioned undercurrent.
Are you also still developing Splash or is
that--is it just released as it is?
>> There's no active work going--the question
was, "Are we still developing Splash?" There's
no active work happening in Splash at the
moment but we're supporting the API that Splash
talks to. So I haven't act--personally seen
it running recently against Wave in a Box
but it--it should work.
>> I [INDISTINCT] I have a demo.
>> Oh, Leonard has a demo of Splash running
against Wave in a Box, fantastic. So, we're
planning to maintain it but there's no active
development going into it right now. I guess
if someone's really keen about that that would
be a fantastic place to jump in and you know,
you could sort of look after that bit of the
code for a while. All right. So if we jump
inside the server box this is the logical
architecture of the inside of the Wave in
a Box server. This is reminiscing of the architecture
that the Google Wave system ran at a higher
scale but we've sort of replicated it inside--inside
one server. And of course, this opened it
up to a scaling later on if we decide to just
put things out in this particular way. So
this large box is labeled server core here,
this is what you might imagine as--it's what
we call the Wave server. So the whole thing
is the Wave in a Box server, and what we call
inside here, you know, it's class name is
Wave server inside the code. And this is a
DOM operation and transform machine. It accepts
operations from clients, transforms them against
the waves data and keeps the history. That's
pretty much all it does. Although it also
has a lot of complexity related to--to a federation
and so on. It accepts apps either from your--its
local clients or apps that have already being
applied and transformed by some federated
server. And so it's responsible for taking
those apps, transforming them if necessary,
and then sending them back out to anyone who's
interested. And anyone who's interested is
anyone who's listening on the wave bus, which
is a virtual bus inside the wave server. All
operations which apply to any all--all deltas
operations which applies to any wavelet hosted
to this server or remotely are pushed out
to the wave bus. And so any software component
listening on the wave bus sees all the wave
traffic and can choose to act on it. So there's
no access controller or anything happening
inside the box everything is global. So there's
a few Wave bus clients of particular note.
Oh, and another thing I should point out,
some of what we'll be talking about in this
talk and other talks, sometimes we'll talk
about how things should be or how we're working
towards them being rather than how they necessarily
are now. So there's a lot of a--I mean, it's--the
code is more complex than this diagram suggests.
We're working towards simplifying it towards
this diagram so I think it's probably best
to talk about how we imagine things in the
way we talk about things. Although sometimes
the code doesn't actually reflect that yet
but it's where we're headed. So the first
Wave bus client is the client front end and
so this is where the web client hooks up.
The web client's WebSocket is coming in from
the outside there. So the client front end
sits on the wave bus and receives all the
deltas and then it does access control and
has this sort of per user session state to
send to the right deltas, to the right client,
so that whichever wave they've got open receives
live updates. So a delta that comes into the
wave server is pushed out on a Wave bus and
then the client front end has all the different
client end points and it determines which
clients have this wave opened and pushes the
delta out to these clients. The client front
end also receives deltas from all the remote
clients, does access control and then pushes
the means of the wave server, submits them
to the server core. And then of course the
server core turns around and that goes back
out on the Wave bus. So that's the client
front end. And there's a bunch of servlets
importing various things. The data and robot
APIs are one big thing that we have servlets
implementing. So these are then not live.
so the client front end is looking after sort
of live sessions that are held open the servlets
sort of, you know, one shop request, typical
web servlet, so the data API is not a live
session. So these servlets answer the--the
data API, the robot API which usually, you
know, quite often involve submitting deltas
to the server core in response to robot operations
and the like. There's also a servlet that--oh
yeah, question?
>> Yeah, just a quick question. I noticed
in with the move to a robot gateway into specific
servers with a specific instance, are we moving
away from an agent framework?
>> What do you mean by agent framework?
>> When [INDISTINCT] first came out, the idea
was to have agents which will then be used
to communicate between different parts of
your system and the wave system. But with
the roadblocks were meant to be built on top
of an agent who was--just going to be doing
a specific task sort of thing as opposed to
Wave?
>> Yes. So the question was, "Are we moving
away from an agent infrastructure which was
sort of first described when we first released
the source code and is in fact the way some
things inside Google Wave work?" Initially,
yes. So that most--the simplest model for
Wave in a Box in, you know, inside one box
is to do this all inside one press. [INDISTINCT]
as agents, we used to refer to as something
instead of sat on the connection that was
a system level service, it could seal the
content and then--so you could imagine implementing
the robot gateway which I haven't got to yet.
Outside of this process but still on a, you
know, close trusted connection to the--to
the Wave server. So at the moment we are implementing
all of these inside one box. When it comes
time for that kind of scaling we'll probably
investigate something like that.
>> It's all right.
>> So yes. Okay. Then the robot gateway talks
to robots. It has a [INDISTINCT] communication,
it can be called by robots, or it calls out
to robots. So as again, it's kind of the client
front end for robots as deltas speed out on
the Wave bus. It checks if robots are involved,
and if robots are involved it sends events
out to robots and then receives their responses,
does things and submits deltas. Leonard will
be talking about the robot gateway right after--right
after me. Oh, that reminds me, is there a
clock that I can look at? The clock on the
wall there by the way doesn't move so don't
look at it. When was I supposed to finish,
10:00?
>> About 10:30.
>> Ten thirty, cool.
>> You have enough.
>> Sweet. And then the bottom box here doesn't
exist yet. These are one of those examples
of things which is how we would like to do
it but it doesn't do it yet. It's indexing.
So, indexing will be as--the indexing services
will provide things like your inbox search
over text to dispense the kind of things,
kind of searches you can do inside Google
Wave, provide folders and so on when we have
them. So the indexing service sits on the
Wave bus and sees everything and then it's
job is to maintain an index of who--of what
waves are in what, who's people's inboxes
and then a text index that's searchable. Initial
plans to sort of shortcut this in Wave in
a Box was to just chip and use the data stores
built in text search whatever it was but that
only does so many things. We can't--it becomes
very difficult to do that ones we have any
kind of per user index state, like if you
archieve a wave we need to write that to disk
somewhere but it doesn't really belong in
the same store where all the wave data is
stored. So, indexing. As we start building
up that kind of data--well, I guess, inbox
ends up in a wave anyway. That's a good example
of something the index stores. Well, I guess
the index will answer the query of what's
in your inbox. So for each wave, we store
your state about which--sort of which blips
you've read in a wave, whether you've put
it a folder or whether you've archived it
inside another wavelet, inside the same wave,
which will--in a way we'll describe later.
But the index it will be [INDISTINCT] asked,
answering the question of what waves are in
my inbox right now. And so as you manipulate
the waves, viewing them, and as new waves
appear, the index will maintain sort of a
live view of what your index looks like and
what various search look like. And so [INDISTINCT]
Wave bus will receive light traffic for that.
So then they made your Wave bus components.
There'll probably be others cropping up as
other services arise, that gives you an idea
of the architecture inside this server. So
there's still a bit of a crafty code lying
around at the moment that we're trying to
get rid off. In particular right now, indexing
is not implemented and there's a bit of a
chip that uses a global wave to represent
people's inboxes. But we're going to get rid
of that real soon as soon as we have search
implemented. So as soon as we have the data
store the system data we'll get rid of that.
So the data stored here--as drawn on any of
the server core is talking to it, and so that--this
link here is the server storing the deltas
on this because it transforms and applies
them. And then the canonical state of a wavelet
is simply the deltas that the server has stored
to disc. But of course other components here
also talks the data store so the attachment
server for example, we have stored attachment
data somewhere, and a robot gateway has a
list of robot somewhere. And they're all stored
in data stores so this diagram simplifies
the data storage story a little bit. But this--those
stores are abstracted away behind interfaces
in the code and so they could all be in fact
be different data stores. Any questions so
far before I move on from the server box?
All right. Any questions on the live wave?
Is there any--anyone watching the live wave?
No?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> Okay.
>> [INDISTINCT] see your slides.
>> Oh, sweet. Thank you. All right. Inside
the client, again, this is a very simplified
picture of the client and not entirely reflective
of how it looks today but it is where they
kind of picture the way we're looking towards
as a very high level picture. So the server
is off to the right here. And sort of the
core flow, the client's job of displaying
live waves to you and letting you interact
with them is the top half of this diagram.
So the client has some kind of socket connection,
a WebSocket or a Flash socket or something
like that back to the server and that socket
is hooked up to what we call the concurrency
control stack. It's the communication stack
for a single Wave. So that looks after performing
operational transfer for you as operations
come in from the server. And as you generate
operations by typing, the CC stack does operational
transform and shows that you are opt to transform
against any apps that you haven't seen as
you're making the key and so that all your--your
intention is preserved from all your interactions.
And then it presents a live view of the wave
and then the web client hooks this up to what's
called the Wave stack which is some codes
that have holding this CC stack and it's the
current state of the wave in memory. And on
top of that, we have the Wave panel, the codename
for our--the new Wave panel we released as
undercurrent, so you'll probably see that
word throughout the code. The Wave panel is
responsible for displaying the wave to you
on screen, rendering the wave and certain
interactions like marking blips as red when
you read them and so on. For each blip inside
the Wave there's an editor. And so, the editor
is a chunk of code we released quite a while
ago now. So the Wave panel is responsible
for, you know, hooking up the edits of the
codes so that when you start typing, the ops
spit out of your editor and then back down
the CC stack up and off to the server after
being transformed. And then, of course, you
can--I guess you can't yet in Wave in a Box
but you can have multiple waves open in theory,
this whole stack is a per wave thing. And
then now, we also have a bunch of servlets
where it serves five times--oh, that's not
a very good diagram--you know, front-ends
to the servlets. And so, the Wave stack uses
the prefix servlet to fetch efficient snapshots
that can be encased by the browser and so
on rather than pumping them over the web--the
WebSocket. So, really, this are just sort
of spec snapshots but there's a bunch of other
servlets, again, the attachment upload servlet
being a good example, that the--we'll use
the data API for Search soon. So here, the
digest panel. The digest panel is the left-hand
panel in Wave. It shows your--at the moment,
you know, your list of waves. But as we begin
implementing Search and things like that it'll
show search results. So that will talk to
some servlet providing the search results
via the data API's search functionality. And
a few great outbox is over to the right of
the client [INDISTINCT] that don't exist yet.
Contact management is something we haven't
attempted to implement yet. And fold is another
sort of Wave management task. Folders and
safe search and so on we also haven't implemented.
We'll be separate client components talking
to some kind of servlets to be live. So it's
a very simplistic overview of the client but
will help you hopefully understand what's
happening if you go delving into the code.
Are there any questions about anything so
far? All right. Well, that's all I had. It
makes it sound really simple, really.
>> I have a question.
>> Yes.
>> What was the primary data across [INDISTINCT]
the Wave buses that the deltas operations
and what are the information that are [INDISTINCT].
>> Yeah, sure. So the question was, "What's
the information that's flowing over the Wave
Bus?" The Wave Bus is deltas. And so, a delta
is a container with a bunch of operations,
operation being sort of an atomic mutation
on the Wave, and the delta bundles in that
we submitted data like the author of the operations,
the timestamp they were applied and so on.
So delta is submitted by clients and processed
by the server core and then deltas come back
out on a Wave bus. Deltas are also what flows
over the client server protocol. The client
front-end basically just does some filtering
and pushes those same deltas back out over
the client server protocol. There is also
means to fetch the snapshot state of a wave.
We don't really think of that as going over
the--of the Wave bus but it follows the same
path.
>> Can you tell the distinction between the
[INDISTINCT] delta and [INDISTINCT]?
>> Yes, there is. We only recently introduced
this distinction serve in the code. So if
you're looking in the--at the code inside
the server now, there's two different classes.
One representing a delta as submitted by the
client and it lacks information like the timestamp,
which is chosen by the server and a signature
which the server computes. And then, the class
name called transform wavelet delta represents
something that's come back out of the server
and as authoritative metadata associated with
it. On the Y, the protocol doesn't yet quite
capture this distinction but we're working
towards that.
>> So I want to touch tomorrow in the Wave
server.
>> Do you want to just talk at the mic so
the stream and such is recorded properly?
>> Tomorrow morning in the Wave server talk,
I'll go over the Wave bus again and be more
specific about the interface. So in the--I
think--so at the level of these diagrams,
it's useful to--so that is two classes called
Wave bus and Wave provider. I think it's useful
to think of both the subscription where you
get the deltas and offer something called
commitment notices to learn when things that
been presented is running out--is broadcast
on the Wave bus and then you can make sort
of RPC procedure calls from these clients
of the Wave bus to the Wave server for--to
request operation--delta history to try and
help--to request snapshots and to submit deltas.
>> Thanks [INDISTINCT]. Question?
>> So there've been mentioned of a snapshot
Wave or Wave snapshots since the optimization.
What made it [INDISTINCT] to have our own
[INDISTINCT]?
>> Sure. The question was, "What's a Wave
snapshot and how are they--how they are useful?"
So, a snap--a snapshot--well, some are delta.
So the history of a wave is purely defined
by its delta. So if you threw away all other
data and just had deltas you would still not
have lost anything, everything else is computed.
A snapshot is simply the result of applying
some initial sequence of these deltas to an
empty wave state. And so the deltas mutate
this state to reach some state, like what
you would--like an initial state you get when
you open a wave in the client that's a snapshot
at some version of the wave or a rendering
of. So, a snapshot is just the resulting state
from applying a bunch of deltas from the start
of the wave. And so they're useful because
that's normally much more of a concise representation
than the delta history. And so, a snapshot
is what we fetch over the client server protocol
when we first commissioned the wave. We ask
the server to compute a snapshot of the current
version and then--and then the client just
sort of directly renders that. Inside the
Wave server, they're also useful. So, the
robot operations that robots apply normally
against some, you know, we fetch a snapshot
of the wave and then mutate it according to
what the robot asked us to do. And then the
deltas that result from that mutation we submit
to the core. Does that answer the question?
>> Yeah. Well, is there any intent to persist
snapshots?
>> "Is there any intent to persist snapshots?"
So they're redundant in that the deltas provide
the whole--all the information you need. We
probably will end up persisting snapshots
periodically. Again, as an efficiency gain
so that when someone asks for a particular
snapshot we can just read one of disc instead
of re-computing the whole thing. We'll probably
store the latest version snapshot. Whenever
we sort of write a bunch of data to disc we'll
store a snapshot of that point as well. Any
other questions? All right. Well, I finished
nice and early. So the next talk is Leonard
talking about the Robot Gateway. And, I guess,
let's start right away. I think we can slightly
have a longer break after Leonard's talk is
done. All right. Fantastic.